[موسيقى]
يمكن لبيت السوس هذه المجموعة ولكن الكود لدينا هو okpo
يجب أن يكون مثالًا قليلًا صغيرًا
الظل لأنه مذكور خلاف ذلك في الإطار
أنت دائما تطلق النار على نفسك أولا
نظرة خاطفة باستمرار ومنظار الرؤية
يمر الوقت
أعطى لاعب كمال الأجسام الجانب الخطأ من الكاميرا
أولا وقبل كل التدليك له
بعض الجمال الجسدي لصعوبة
من المهم جدًا كيف تحصل عليه ولكن تأكل منه
وهو أمر سيء ولكن الرحيل عن الضرر موجود
تقييم فقط
كمال الاجسام عموما مثل هذا الموضوع هو نفسه
أيضا الفن خدعة صغيرة
بعضها ليس كبيرًا جدًا ، ولكن من أجل
يسجل نسبة تعويض المتابعة
التظاهر ، أي يتم إنشاء الوهم
صورة
[موسيقى]
أمازون فقد ابتكرته بنفسها وفي
لنفترض أنهم يعرفون ذلك بالضبط من أجل هؤلاء
الاسم المستعار كمال الاجسام لا يزال كمال الاجسام
هي أيضا قوية جدا
هناك حقًا لا أعرف أي ثقافة
قطارات الملل بمثل هذه الأوزان إذن
هل ما زالت لديها أوزان تدريب
سيسمح لك بالدخول في أي مسابقة
في رفع الأثقال وبشكل عام بدون
هناك مشاكل خاصة تتفوق على الصحافة
الكذب هنا بالتأكيد ستكون كذلك دائمًا
أحد المتنافسين الموقرين
الدمبل 30 كجم مقيم دومو
أقدام لا تشوه 1 2 كبروا في السن وتموت لي
يكرهون ولا وضع جيد
عليك أن تعمل بجد
يستخدمه كل شخص مثلك لا تكشف
أن لديهم رمزًا مناسبًا لك وحدك
دون الكشف عن مناوشات تتظاهر ناتاشا أنا
أنا أقول الحقيقة ، أنت لا تعرف كيف تفعل ذلك ، و
لك انها مثل رسالة صينية
بالطبع تناولت لوحات كمال الأجسام
بالفعل بعد لقاء ناتاشا ، هذا
أصبح الموضوع مثيرًا للاهتمام في ذلك الوقت
آسف وزني أفضل 80 كيلوغراما
ناتاشا ، على سبيل المثال ، من الممل أن نفهم
النظرية بشكل عام ، وهذا هو ، كما كانت
اعتاد أن يكون أكثر عملية من
لطالما كنت مهتمًا بالنظرية
فهم الجزء النظري
على هذا التمرين لممارسة
رهيب أنك لا تفعل أي كاميرا على الإطلاق
من المؤسف أنك تفعل ذلك لكنني لن أفعل
بدأ يتكلم مثل هذه الكلمات الصاخبة
مدير تاريخ المنتج هل هناك أي شيء آخر
الشيء هو أنني شخص
بشكل عام ، كل شيء يحاول ، بشكل جيد ، نسبيًا
ترتيب نعم هذا هو أنا أساعد و
جلب بعض شؤونها في بعض
على الأقل أمر تقريبي ، أي لديها
لا رغبة في التواصل مع أي
وكلاء للتفاوض على حجم التصوير و و
هذه هنا
وسائل الإعلام هي بالفعل وظيفة من أجلها
يحصل طالما أنه لائق
الأجر هكذا
حقا من المنطقي من خلال هذا بالفعل
افعلها بشكل أفضل ، بل إنها نقطة
عرض أعلن التنبؤ بنا
الليلة تأثير خاص
الضيف
كان انفجار دماغ الفتاة حديقة
بعد رؤيتها مباشرة للفتاة تتوق إليها
الوقت الضائع في صالة الألعاب الرياضية
وناتاليا الوحيدة
مخاوف كوزنتسوفا على ناتاشا مساء الخير
مرحبًا بالجميع سوف يقوم بالبناء
حامل سجل الشارع في الصحافة مقاعد البدلاء و
الرفعة المميتة
ماجستير في الرياضة من الدرجة الدولية في
اتضح أن armlifting بدأت في الرابعة عشرة من عمري
قررت فقط صالة رياضية جميلة وقليلا
اسحب ذبابة صغيرة تحت قدميك
فتاة واندفع لديهم شيء
اتضح أنه أمر محفز للغاية
واحد حرفيا في غضون بضعة أشهر
التدريب لم يلاحظه المدرب و
عرضت على الأداء في "تشابلن" المحلية
ما الذي أفعله في كمال الأجسام
بالغ
[تصفيق]
لقد جئت من إقليم ترانس بايكال في ذلك الوقت
مصمم لمدة 40 عامًا وأنا هناك بالإضافة إلى 40 عامًا
تفكك وبدأ يمشي في شرسة
تجميد
أساتذة ولكن ليس لي السباق
لم تكن نوادي اللياقة مثل
موسكو في ذلك الوقت كان هناك مثل هذا
كرسي هزاز صحي ، ولكن عندما أدركت ذلك في
هذه الرياضة
أنني أستطيع أن أفعل شيئًا ما ، لكن ما الذي حققته في ذلك
ليس هناك ما يكفي من الرصاص لي
تجريب لعرقلة أو بلوق
مفعل
وجدت نفسي ثم ضغطنا كم أكثر
سيد عادي للوحدات الرياضية 175
كيلوغرام من ملاحظة الصدر 10 1
وفي المصارعة كان ذلك بالتأكيد
بطبيعة الحال
حسنًا ، لقد حصلوا بالفعل على الاتحاد
في الواقع ، ذهب الكثير من الرياضيين إلى الفراش
التي تحرك مليون يتصرفون
الاتحاد الذي يسمح بالتحكم فيه
نحن نبني نفس الشيء ونرفع موضوع المنشطات إليه
نظيفة لمن يصل إلى النهر على الإطلاق
الرياضة وكنت تعتقد أنك أكلت ثم كل شيء
200 ربما القرية ليست كذلك أنا
الوقوف الأكبر هو هائل
الاتحاد الذي ينطلق أكثر
أقوى الرياضيين في العالم لكن في الوقت الحالي
لحظة أنا أصغر رياضي
من لديه بطاقة احترافية ولكن
أنا هانك التثبيت
[موسيقى]
إذا صعدت على خشبة المسرح لأداء ثم مع
بدرجة عالية من الاحتمال
تقول أنها تخرج يفوز
في الحياة الحقيقية بالفعل كيف ناتاليا الأمازون
لا توجد مثل هذه المرأة العادية تماما
عادي تماما المصالح نعم بعد ذلك
هناك مضيفة جيدة هناك
الزوجة تجيد الطبخ وتحب التسوق
أي بغض النظر عن مدى أهميته
لا يختلف عن الناس العاديين
إلى جانب كونها قوية
هذا كل شئ
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وسوف أضعها على قدمي أمس
كتب أندريه لك في التعليقات
يجب أن يتم القبض على ناتاليا وسيئة
احترق
اقلب ساقك بقوة هنا ، لكن هذه
مفاتيح الجزء
أنا أحترم ناتاشا ناتاليا بطريقتي الخاصة
أنا أحب أن أقول ما تعتقده
إفطار ملون أو إطلالة على المدينة
حرفية إذا أتيت للتدرب غدًا
لكن من المهم تجفيف المدينة ، فلن أتمكن من ذلك
انظر متى تكون أفضل مدينة
[موسيقى]
هذا رجل رائع جدا من صميم القلب له
احترام
هذا الرجل سوف تفعل
[موسيقى]
الفتيات تحبه
الشكل المجيد تشكل
[موسيقى]
إنها من أشد المعجبين بي
أمهات شابات مختلفات
ربة منزل هذا السؤال هو خيانة
أشكال وهذا هو و
ولكن ما نفس النجوم العالم حقا
يبدو مثل
[موسيقى]
تم أخذ الوزن الزائد كيلو أصفر
يرضي زير النساء
لا تهتم وكيف يريد الآن
لدي حوالي 7 و
لا أعرف ماذا أسمي هذا المشروع
لكن الفكر تومض من خلال رأسي للاتصال
له
ذهبت مرة واحدة إلى المتجر هناك لصحيفة
جريدة
لذلك أعتقد أنه ربما يوجد لا co2
مرات انه بن كيفية منعه
لقد كنت مستمرا لعدة سنوات
يذهب إلى القناة
التقى 5
يمكن قناة تفعل علاقة لها
يظهر الفيديو في عداد المفقودين
أقول ذهبت مع ناتاشا
الآن من الضروري حماية أكثر المؤمنين بك
المشجعين دائما دعونا نأكل معا هم
بالطبع يمكن أن تكون نشطة للغاية ، نعم أنت
سمعت بشكل عام
بضع كلمات أود أن تكون فوق تحفة
فنجان آخر دعونا نلتقط الصور
تمر الناس في انتظار roistat
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نحن سوف
[موسيقى]
كان لدي حالة عندما كنت صديقة في كثير من الأحيان
وضع الولد المتوهج أمام الجديد
بعد عام ، ذهب الوالدان لمعرفة ذلك
لكن هذا كان قبل كمال الاجسام
لكنه بدا حتى أقل من معتوه
ما حدث لم يكن بهذه الروعة
لا يزال يتخطى المشاغبين مثل مدرستك
فصول دراسية نعم ولكن كان لدي بعض
يمكن أن تكون الرغبات دائمًا مشغولة بشيء ما
الرياضة القتالية كل هؤلاء العشاق
الكاراتيه ولكن الوالدين اللوز على ولدت لنا
[موسيقى]
ليس هناك الكثير من الاقتراحات التي تصل إليه
تصوير أفلام بعض المسلسلات وأنا
أنا قست
عقد مع مسرح البولشوي لعدة مرات
سنوات
أنت تنادي قراصنةه ولكن جميعهم تقريبًا 3
ع
أنا في مرحلة الاهتمام بدور مثل
ش الأمازون على المسرح الكبير
على وجه التحديد لأنني فعلت ما لم أفعله
أحب ذلك ونحن كمال الاجسام نتحمله
تسمى علامات التبويب ، ربما تعلمت ذلك
لم يصل الخير بالفعل لم تكن أنت
ديمتري لا أحد يعرفني
خلاف ذلك ، إما بنفسي ، سأقف بالتأكيد على
حالة نماز للجمال تحولت
بسرعة مثل ما لديك
تكمن الروح
[تصفيق]